hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge wenn
ich ihn fünfmal so reinsch sich direkt
das max und luca hier toll auf der couch
sitzen oder sie schauen sich süßer damit
ein flugzeug extra eingeflogen um mich
zu sehen welchen vermieter ja dann doch
etwas zu essen machen luca macht jetzt
für beide erstmal schön kuchen luca so
macht man keinen kuchen weiße torte
fortsetzt luca weißer torte fast wie so
guckt er max willst du denn hin luca du
machst jetzt deine scheiße hier wollte
es für max jetzt kommt ja mach doch
deine scheiss torte jetzt man ja bla bla
alles super toll ja wir stärken unsere
beziehung und luca macht jetzt mal jetzt
schlafen die breite einfach schon warum
dann jetzt schlafen die schon ist es 17
uhr und beiden schlafen als ob sie das
getan haben luca von mangelnder hygiene
angewidert der isabeau leicht dreckig
folgender fortschritt max liegt auf der
couch schon schläft luca liegt in der
badewanne und schläft ich hoffe der
stimmlich alt aber ich hab kann einfach
mal die zeit vor gespielt und jetzt sind
es gerade irgendwie so weiß ich nicht
drei stunden später gerade mal wieder
die zeit angehalten
und wollte halt schauen ob dies
geschafft haben zu kochen und sehe dabei
dass hier muss ich da noch was zu sagen
ist der dumm bist mit blattmann und
jetzt hat der hunger ist glaubt ja wohl
die beide nicht hingekriegt haben zu
kochen habe ich jetzt einfach mal ein
caterer engagiert der jetzt ein caterer
soll kochen und nicht mit hier kocht
doch und die caterer dame macht uns
jetzt etwas nein sie holt sich ein buch
mach uns was zu essen
die caterer dame hat noch kein mal was
zu essen für uns gemacht sondern bisher
nur das was sie denn überhaupt hier luca
liegt er im bett und pennt steht auf und
jetzt max geht jetzt schlafen und grün
hier in max schön am schlafen und lokal
was ist los mit diesem chip bald hat er
nur migräne oder socom luca wenz mit max
nichts wir dann macht sich doch mal
wenigstens hier an
den
eigentlich sollte gar nicht gehen die
macht uns traurig was zu essen max und
lukas schlafen und tk tante räumt auf
und macht ihr alter das ist ja richtig
anzieht strukturen und die badewanne ich
werde ja nicht mehr ich kaufe mal kurz
ein bisschen beleuchtung hier weil wir
ohne roboter lampe wir haben quasi
nirgends so beleuchten de einen partner
lampe wir nirgendwo beleuchtung der
kompletten bruder haben habe ich mir
gedacht wenn man sinnvoll ein bisschen
lampen jetzt aufzustellen so dass ja es
ist doch also es ist jetzt relativ hell
darin tatsächlich ich sage euch jetzt
schon freuen in der nächsten folge
cheaten wir uns geld und ziehen um ihn
richtig krasse villa mit vier anderen
leuten oder so das wird geil luca fühlt
sich komplett scheiße weil er ich glaube
er ist sogar in scheiße gebadet worden
oder so wieder aussieht die caterer
tante macht sex im alter wie geil dieses
spiel man sieht sie sogar im spiegel die
essen gerade das erste essen von der
catering tante und es ist die muss
definitiv gefallen warum kultur agent
max so an ich habe diese catering frau
eingestellt damit sie uns essen macht
was wirklich geil ist aber die beiden
sind da eigentlich eher so voll am
verrecken fassen ich weiß nicht was er
will wenn ich auf bahnen clique dann
ist er da automatisch von abgeneigt und
dann wenn ich hier auf toiletten drücke
dann ist er da auch von abgeneigt aber
er fühlt sich voll und wohl nicht weiß
gar nicht was mit dem los lukas städte
einmal nur um und fühlt sich übel
scheiße und max hamers geil ich liebe
dich luca bin alleine hier alles klar
wird gesagt luca soll die einfach mal so
leidet schließlich einfach mal verpisst
hier soll ja komm dann anbrüllen dann
über outfit schotten dann noch noch
nochmal ein getränk werfen blue card
sich gerade einfach auf eine parkbank
gelegt der typ tut mir so leid luca ist
übelste fühlt sich mega unwohl und den
unbedingt baden und duschen und sich
frisch machen aber diese catering
verpisst sich einfach nicht aus dem bad
säckinger rathaus lady kommt da nicht
raus
ich glaube diese kleine lampe versperrt
der so ein bisschen den weg dass die da
einfach nicht weg ja wir das problem
gelöst und jetzt nimmt lukas ich erst
mal ein schönes schaumbad macht sich
frisch yaman geiser bagdad gegeben etwa
mal bei big bang theory der serie mit 3
jamann
ich hab mal kräftig essen die beiden
sind tatsächlich gerade schon zusammen
im bad
ich würde sagen wir beenden das video
hier und schauen mal was von den beiden
da jetzt noch passieren wird wenn euch
das video gefallen meine damen und
herren würde ich mich über eine
bewertung freund sims macht mir übel so
viel spaß deswegen wird es definitiv
weiterhin kommen allerdings nur so
einmal wöchentlich denke ich schreib mir
nochmal in die kommentare ob ich dann im
nächsten teil bieten soll
ob das überhaupt geht und